Over the past four and a half years we have
made hundreds of videos here on Journey to the
Microcosmos, and in that time we have seen
some stars rise to the top to become the
true celebrities of the microcosmos. So, this year
we've taken some of our most popular microscopic
friends and put together a 2024 calendar featuring
highlights from some of your favorite Microcosmos
episodes.  We've got your tardigrades, your rotifers,
your amoeba, and Hydra, but we've also got what I
think might be my favorite, the long-necked Lacrymaria, the sea monkeys with their dark past, and
a couple of discoveries that James was shocked
to come across like the Spirostomum and the Legendrea.
Each page features a little blurb explaining
what you're looking at and a fantastic photo
that showcases our Master of Microscopes James
Weiss's work as a microscopist. We love getting
to make this show each and every week and we
are continually blown away by the support you
all have shown for it. So, if you'd like to bring
the microcosmos home with twelve dazzling photos to
show off on your wall, pick up your 2024 Journey
to the Microcosmos calendar over at microcosmos.store
and if you'd like to grab some other
calendars from our sibling channels, Eons,
Bizarre Beasts, and SciShow, you can do so at complexlycalendars.com
All those links of course are in the description.